they're called big boxes or a reason the
average target is 135,000 square feet
and there's this store we're gonna have
sandwiches salads beverages people can
buy one single roll of paper towels you
guys have a big neat section a lot of
college students they need a tank top
this is target express 85 percent
smaller than a traditional target it's
about the size of your local pharmacy
the format is really designed to work in
dense urban areas where people either
live where they work or where they go to
school just blocks from the University
of Minnesota campus target Express
caters to college students yeah I think
so here when we have a home section its
geared to outfit your dorm or that first
apartment in food its those staples to
make meals it's grabbing the options to
grab on your way to class and so we
really try to tailor what we offer to
the student that we have here so it's
not just about size it's important that
we set the tone from the moment you walk
in whether it's the University of
Minnesota product whether it's the the
sign in the mural that's designed by an
alum of the university we want the
guests to get that local feel right away
in its test store Target Express keeps
changing its approach curating the
experience to fit local needs another
adjustment we made for the students is
that we have a lot more of our own brand
so up and up as it is a brand the target
owns and students specifically ask for
that because they saw it as a way to
save money and to stretch their budget
farther but can students an urbanite
save target the retailer needs to regain
customers trust after its data breach
that affected tens of millions of
customers it also has to boost traffic
the reason we think they should do a lot
more small boxes is that they're really
under penetrating their core demographic
which is women between 25 and 44 it's
really a matter of getting their their
their brand and their store to their
customers and at the same time improve
performance in the larger stores the
first thing that's coming us to a new
imagine has to do is fix target so job
number one
fixing target core fixing food getting
frequency up compared to competitors
like Walmart and Kroger target falls far
behind in sales per square foot but
Target Express could help change that
with eight more stores set to open this
year
you